today i want to show you something you
might not have seen before
in this course we will use html5 canvas
element
and plain vanilla javascript to create
interactive
animated particle effects we will start
with a very simple project where we
learn
about the draw image and get image data
built in canvas methods
and how to use them to create a pixel
array then
we take it to the next level and use
that pixel array data to make our
particles do amazing things
let me show you the real power of html
canvas using just basic
fundamental javascript tools and
techniques if you get stuck or you need
some help with the code we are about to
write
you can message me on twitter or catch
me somewhere on my youtube channel
special thanks to bo from freecodecamp
for letting me share this course with
you
i hope you get some value out of this
let me take you through the code
step by step and explain how to use html
canvas to create beautiful things
[Music]
in index.html i create html canvas
element with an id of canvas 1.
i link style css and script.js files
in style css i target the body element
and give it black
background canvas will have border solid
white
top 50 left 50
position absolute width 800 pixels
and height 450 pixels
transform translate minus 50 to minus 50
will center our absolutely positioned
canvas element
both vertically and horizontally
in script js the usual basic canvas
setup constant variable i call canvas is
equal to document.getelementbyid
and i pass it id i gave it in index html
which was
canvas one constant ctx shortcut for
context
equals canvas variable from line 1 dot
get context 2d
this way i make my ctx variable an
instance
of canvas 2d api object and i can call
all
built-in canvas methods on this variable
now such as ctx fill rectangle to draw a
rectangle
and so on canvas width will be 800
and canvas height will be 450. these
values need to be the same as values we
set for canvas in css file to make sure
we get the correct scaling
i will bring an image with dimensions of
800 times 450 pixels
to my project first i create a custom
variable i call for example
image 1 and i set it equal to new image
new is a special keyword in javascript
and image with capital i
is a special built-in class constructor
doing this will just create a new blank
object
and assign it values and properties
based on built-in javascript image
blueprint
simply said we just created blank new
image object
that comes with src property if you
consulate image
1 you will see it i set this src
source property to path to my own image
like this
image 1 src equals image1png
for you the path might be different
remember that the path must be relative
to wherever you placed your script.js
file inside your project structure
for javascript to be able to see your
image
now i will try to draw the image by
using built-in draw image method
if i just give it three arguments like
this the first one is the image i want
to draw
so my image one variable from line six
the second argument is the x coordinate
and the third one
is vertical y coordinate where i want to
draw it on canvas
i want the image to start from
coordinates 0 0 which is the top left
corner
the reason the canvas is still blank and
no image has been drawn is because
javascript code runs very fast
even though the image loads relatively
fast as well it is not yet loaded when
draw image method runs
i have to take variable image 1 from
line 6 and since i gave it src attribute
on line 7
i can give it event listener for load
event
image 1 add event listener and
when a load event occurs which means
after the image has been fully loaded
only then run the following code i
placed inside the callback function
if i put the draw image method inside
this callback function
the image will be drawn so this was the
first issue we face when handling images
on canvas
solved draw image built-in method has
three versions depending on how many
arguments we pass to it
we use the shortest one here with only
three arguments
we can also pass it five arguments where
the fourth and the fifth one
stand for width and height of the image
my image is exactly the same size as my
canvas so i don't need it but if your
image is a different size you can give
it different width and height
doing that you can scale your image
however you want by passing it different
values here
the third version of draw image method
takes nine arguments and we can use it
to crop out pieces of a sprite sheet for
example
like we did in my game development
series to create animated characters
we will not do that today i want to know
colors of each individual pixel
that makes up this image html canvas
provides us with a built-in method
that can do just that i create a
constant variable called
scannedimage and i set it equal to
ctx.getimagedata
this method takes four arguments which
define what area of canvas
i want to scan for pixel information i
want to scan the entire canvas so i pass
it
0 0 for starting coordinates and canvas
width and canvas height
for the end coordinates this method
scans all pixels on canvas
it goes from left to right row by row
from top to bottom
the order is important if you want to
determine coordinates for each pixel
it scans all pixels and it returns image
data object
if i console lock my scanned image
variable we can see that object here
let's open it and we can see it contains
something called data
which is an array we also have height
and width properties which correspond
with the size of an area i scanned
with the get image data method and it
also has some prototype methods which
are not important now
if i open data we can see it's a massive
array
but it's not a regular javascript array
i can see it is called something like
uint8 clamped array and it contains
one million four hundred and forty
thousand elements uint
eight clamped array is a special type of
array it is very simple basically each
of its elements has to be a number
from a certain range it can only contain
numbers between 0 and 255
if you used css before you remember rgb
color declaration and you will know that
any color can be declared by combining
three numbers
between 0 and 255 and that's what this
is
we are basically looking at color values
uh numbers
that make up colors of each individual
pixel
but it is a bit strange because each
element in the array contains only one
number and we actually need four numbers
red green and blue and alpha for opacity
the way this array is structured is that
each pixel is spread into four
elements so the first four elements in
the array combined
are rgba color value for the first pixel
the next four values are rgba for the
second pixel and so on
i can see that this array has one
million four hundred and forty thousand
elements
now that we know that four elements make
one pixel i also know that my image is
made out of one million
four hundred and forty thousand divided
by four which is
three hundred and sixty thousand pixels
it makes complete sense because my image
is eight hundred times four hundred and
fifty pixels in width and height
and 800 times 450 is also 360 thousand
these pixels are organized in rows from
left to right starting at the top left
corner so the first pixel
is 1 70 139
1 is right 70 is green 139 is blue
so that's rgb and alpha of this pixel is
247
alpha or opacity in this array is also
declared in a range between 0 which is
invisible
to 255 which is fully visible
that's one thing that's different from
the standard rgba color declaration
we use in css where alpha is a number
between 0 and 1.
i was able to scan my image with no
issues but in some browsers
due to cross-origin resource sharing
security you will get an
error that says something like canvas
has been tainted
by cross-origin content and we cannot
scan it for image data
i don't really know if people can
actually put viruses in images or
something
chrome for example considers your
locally stored images as cross-origin
unless you run this code through a
server
if you ever experience this problem when
scanning image data with a get image
data method for your creative coding
projects
instead of trying to navigate through
server settings and so on
there is an easy work around you can
actually convert any image into data
string and place that string directly
into your file
this will avoid all cross-origin
resource sharing issues
we can convert an image into data string
using
two data url built in javascript method
just by calling it on the image but
today i will just do it using this quick
free online tool if you google png to
base64
this will also work on jpeg images and
other types by the way not just pngs
i go to this address onlinepngtools.com
convert png to base64 you can just drag
and drop your image here
it doesn't have to be in png format on
the right hand side it will generate
base64 string
that contains all data we need to draw
this image with javascript
without needing the actual image file if
your string doesn't start with data
colon image
like mine does make sure you tick this
checkbox down here that says create a
valid data image url
so i just copy this huge long string in
script js on line 7 instead of using the
image file as a source
if you ever get tainted canvas error in
console
just replace the path to the image with
this long data string
and it will fix everything
it will give me exactly the same image
like this you can see in the console
that it contains
identical image data and everything it
is the same image
so as i said this data array i see in
console when i console log my scan image
variable
contains all pixel that make up my image
the image was scanned from top left
corner
going left to right row by row and every
set of four elements in this array
contains rgba values for one pixel
this is all i need to manipulate colors
in my image i can save that pixel array
in a separate variable
if i want let's call it scanned data
and it's equal to scanned image from
line 12 dot
data which is the uint8 cloud array we
see in the console
i can for example create a for loop that
will cycle through the entire array
notice i don't do i plus plus at the end
but i do i
plus equals 4 because i know each time
we skip by 4
we have new pixel so first i will be 0
because arrays start from 0 not from 1
then the second will be 4
then 8 and so on let's make our image
grayscale
there is one strange thing going on with
colors
we know that any color is a combination
of certain amount of red green
and blue i'm not sure if you knew but if
you take any value between 0 and 255
and assign the same value as red green
and blue like this
you will get a shade of gray from dark
to very light
this is not a canvas thing this is how
rgb colors work in general
so what i can do is take color value for
each pixel
calculate average and assign the same
average value as red
green and blue on that same pixel
turning it to grayscale
i create a constant variable called
total which will be a sum of values for
red
green and blue we are jumping through
the array
four pixels at a time so scanned data i
is always the red pixel value
scanned data i plus 1 is always the
green pixel
and scanned data i plus 2 is always blue
then there will be alpha and then we
have another red and so on
average color value is simply total sum
divided by three because we achieved
that sum by adding
three numbers now i have the average
color value and i need to assign that
same value to all
three colors in this pixel to turn it
into grayscale
so scanned data i red pixel is equal to
average color value variable from line
17
scanned data i plus 1 green pixel is
gonna be the same average color value
and also blue pixel scanned data i plus
2 is equal to average color
value now i reassigned color values in
my scanned data array i declared on line
14
and i want to use it and override data
array on the image
so scanned image variable dot data
i set its built-in data array to my
altered array with grayscale colors
now i use built input image data method
which simply paints data
from the given image data object onto
the canvas
i pass it my altered scanned image and i
want it to be drawn from coordinates
0 0 we can also manipulate individual
color levels like this for example
i know there is a css filter property
called grayscale
that allows us to do this with one line
of code but we wouldn't know how to scan
image for pixel data
and how to go from here to create more
advanced particle effects
which is exactly what we will do in the
next episode this is why i wanted to
take you through the basic concept
slowly
because once you have full mental
picture of what's going on here you will
be able to better
understand the trick i will teach you
next time where i make particles move at
different speeds
based on brightness of underlying image
layer
it's going to be more advanced than this
but i will do my best to help you
understand
hope you are learning something new
today if you do click the like please
so now we understand how to draw image
on canvas
how to analyze it for pixel data and how
to manipulate color values of these
pixels
let's take it one step further and use
index of that pixel
in pixel array to calculate its x and y
position on canvas
once we have that information we can do
amazing things in this next part i will
show you how to create simple particle
system
and we will make these particles flow
over canvas based on data from
an image we will make them move faster
over dark areas
and much slower over light areas we will
remove all pixels
and recreate the entire image from a
stream of flowing particles
let's start in index.html by creating
html5 canvas element
i give it id of canvas1 i also link css
stylesheet and javascript file here in
style css i use asterisk selector to
target all elements on the page and i do
global reset to make sure
our styles are the same across different
browsers margin 0
padding 0 box size and set to body box
and let's also do black background
i give canvas border 2 pixels solid
white and i center it by setting its
position
50 from top this will actually only work
if i set its position to absolute
left will also be fifty percent and
transform translate minus fifty percent
minus fifty percent will center it both
vertically and horizontally i make the
canvas exactly the same size as the
image i will be using
so for you it might be different my
image is five hundred times 706 pixels
everything else will be done with
javascript in script js file
i will start by bringing my image into
the project so constant variable i call
for example my image and i set it equal
to new
image now i can give it src property
which could point to an image file
but because some browsers don't like it
when you analyze pixels of image
with get image data when that image is
not hosted on the same server
to avoid all different kinds of cross
cross-origin resource
sharing errors i will convert our image
into url string
that way the image itself is part of
javascript file and everything will work
without
errors we can use javascript to convert
the image but for speed today let's use
a website
that will do it for us i google
something like png to base64
and i choose this link my image can be
any image format it doesn't have to be
png
here i can just drag and drop image i
will be using my advice is to make the
image as small as possible otherwise you
will get a very long data string
and since we need to be cycling through
these pixels later with javascript
smaller image will improve your
performance also if you saw the final
effect you don't need very fine
image resolution for this effect to look
great
so i made my image as small as possible
you can go even smaller if you are
having any performance issues
i drag and drop it here and i convert it
to base 64.
for us to be able to use it we need
string to start with data
colon image so make sure you tick this
checkbox here
now i copy this extremely long data
string which just basically converted
the entire image into a line of code so
we won't need
the actual image file at all i paste
that code on line 2
to bring the image into our project
now the usual canvas setup const canvas
equals to document.getelementbyid and i
pass it canvas 1
the id i gave it earlier ctx
shortcut for context is equal to this
canvas variable
dot getcontext2d now we have
access to all 2d canvas drawing methods
i set canvas width and canvas height to
be the same values i declared in style
css to make sure
the scaling is right now i draw the
image on canvas by using built-in html
canvas method
called draw image it has three versions
we will use the middle version of this
method
that expects five arguments the first is
the image i want to draw
so my image variable from line one
i want the image to start from top left
corner of canvas so coordinates 0
0 and i want it to cover the entire
canvas area so
end coordinates of image rectangle will
be canvas with canvas height
sometimes drawing your image this way
will not work for you because the draw
image method
only works when image has been fully
loaded
to make sure we avoid any potential
errors we can wrap this whole thing
in event listener since we gave our
image src property we can now listen for
load event
on it like this and in callback function
only after the image has been fully
loaded
we run all the code that depends on that
image
i will just put everything inside like
this why not we are now all
set let's create a simple particle
system that will produce a set of
falling particles to flow
over the image i create a led variable
called particles array
and i set it equal to an empty array i
use led here so that i can reassign it
to a new empty array later
if i want to i create a constant
variable called number of particles
and i set it to let's say 5000
i create a javascript class called
particle with capital p
we will use it to create 5 000 similar
particle data objects
and we will push them inside particles
array from line 12.
constructor is a mandatory method on
javascript class
and it will contain blueprint for each
individual particle
this dot x horizontal x coordinate will
be a random number between a zero and
canvas
width i want particles to kind of splash
over the image from top so i set
start and distance y horizontal
coordinate to zero
you can also do other things here maybe
you want the particles to flow from
bottom to top
or from left to right or maybe you want
them to spiral around in a circle you
would adjust
starting x and y based on the final
effect you are going for
falling speed will be 0 at first i will
also have velocity which will be a
random number between
0 and 0.5 basically here i have falling
speed which will
be calculated based on brightness of
background
so particles will fall over black areas
very fast
and over light areas of the image much
slower
velocity is here just to give it some
additional randomness
i think it will look good particles will
have random size between 1 and 2.5
pixels for example
update method will calculate particle
position for each frame before we draw
it
let's start simply by adding plus one to
a horizontal y-coordinate
once particles fall below the bottom
edge of canvas
i want them to reset to position zero up
top
so they can fall down again at the same
time
i will also give them different random
horizontal x position
this is important because particles will
fall slower over light areas of the
image
actually rather than to have all
particles fall at the same speed we can
randomize it a bit
this dot y plus equals this dot velocity
and velocity on line 20 is a random
number between 0
and 3.5 custom draw method will simply
just draw a circle to represent each
particle
begin path to start drawing fill style
will be white
ctx arc to draw a circle i pass it x and
y
size start angle and end angle
then i call ctx fill to fill circular
pathway color
i create a custom function called init
shortcut for initialize
this function will just have a for loop
that will run as many times depending on
number of particles variable
in this case 5000
each time it runs i call built-in push
method on particles array from line 12.
push method places whatever we pass to
it at the end of the array
so i pass it new particle the new
keyword will trigger particle class
constructor on line
16. it will create one new blank
particle object
and assign it properties and randomized
values
based on the blueprint for loop will run
5000 times filling particle array with
5000
randomized particle objects now i call
init to fill the array
function animate will be our main
animation loop first i want a
semi-transparent black rectangle to be
drawn over the canvas for every frame
this will give particles fading trails i
set global alpha
to 0.05 this just specifies transparency
value that is applied to shapes and
images on canvas
0 is fully transparent one is fully
opaque
now i set fill style to rgb 0
0 0 which is black color
i draw a rectangle that covers the
entire canvas ctx
fill rect starting coordinates 0 0 and
in coordinates canvas with canvas height
i will cycle through the entire
particles array
and for each particle object in the
array i call their associated update
method from line 23
and a draw method we declared on line
30.
this for loop will cycle through all
5000 particles for each frame of
animation
it will recalculate their position with
update method
and it will draw them at their new
coordinates with draw method
now i just call animate to kick off
animation loop
this will not work because i also have
to call a request animation frame here
and i pass it animate
request animation frame is a built-in
javascript method
when i pass it animate the name of its
parent function from line 43
that way animate will run all its code
and it will just call itself
again here on line 51 create an
animation loop
through a programming principle called
recursion when function calls itself
over and over that worked now we have
falling white particles that leave
trials
perfect i can temporarily copy draw
image call from line 10 and i put it
inside animation loop
so that we can see the original image
for now
particles are falling and ignoring the
image how do i make them fall at
different speeds
based on brightness of the area they are
moving over
one way to do that is to create a
brightness map of the entire image
it will correspond to x and y
coordinates of each pixel
then i can run this information against
particle's current x and y position
and adjust particle's speed based on its
current coordinates let's do it step by
step
first i create a new led variable called
mapped image
this will be an empty array at first my
goal is to have this array hold
brightness value of each pixel in the
image
along with that pixels x and y
coordinates so i can compare it to x and
y coordinates
of each particle and adjust their
movement speed accordingly
so on the first page load we just draw
image on canvas here on line 10.
i create a custom variable called for
example pixels and i set it equal to ctx
dot get image data
built in canvas method this method scans
area of canvas for pixel information and
it will return
an array like object that holds red
green
blue and alpha value for each individual
pixel in the scanned area
i want to scan the entire canvas so i
pass it 0 0 as
starting coordinates and canvas with
canvas height
as the end coordinates so now my custom
pixels variable holds
whatever get image data returned after
scanning the designated area
in our case the entire canvas if i count
to lock pixels
i see this returned image data object
if i open it it contains array called
data
it also contains height and width
attributes that correspond to width and
height of the scanned area
we scan the entire canvas so width and
height correspond to canvas width and
canvas height from lines 7
and 8. let's inspect the data array you
can see it is called
uint clamped array that means unassigned
integer
so it can only contain elements that are
whole numbers with no decimal points
it also says clamped because these
numbers are limited to a range
between 0 and 255 if you work with css
before
you know that in rgba color declaration
every color
can be declared by combination of red
green
and blue with values between 0 and 255
for each
we established that each element in this
data array could only be a number
between
0 and 255. if you look at the data
structure you can see that every 4
pixels in the array
combined create rgba color declaration
of
1 pixel in our image so this one for
example
is 0 for red 0 for green 0 for blue
and 255 for alpha opacity
in this case alpha is also declared as a
value between 0 which is fully
transparent
to 255 fully opaque
we can double check if you are right
about this we have an array of 1 million
four hundred and twelve thousand
elements and we know that each
four elements in this array represent
rgba
color value of one pixel so one million
four hundred and twelve thousand divided
by four is
350 000. these numbers depend on the
size of the image you uploaded so for
you
it might be different we know the image
i'm using is 500 pixels wide
and 706 pixels high so 500 times
706 is also 353
000 so that checks out let's look at the
pixels with color that are not black
for example here we have 111 for red 83
for green
blue and 255 for alpha then 139 is right
of the next pixel and so on so now we
understand how the color data returned
by getimagedata method is organized
we can cycle through it and save it in
our own array and since we know width
and height of the scanned area
we can calculate x and y-coordinates of
each pixel
since we know how many pixels fit on one
row and we know how many rows
and how many columns our image has this
is the only a bit more difficult part in
this tutorial so if you are a beginner
keep in mind this is not easy
don't feel bad if you struggle to
imagine what exactly is going on i made
a beginner friendly version of this
technique
where we cycle through all pixels and
turn image into grayscale
sometimes it's easier to first try this
with a simple project
i will link it in the video description
we will cycle through every pixel in
this image
row by row from left to right starting
from the top left corner
so the first for loop will have a
vertical y coordinate at
zero our image is 500 pixels wide so y
will be 0 and x will be 0 1
2 3 all the way to 500 then we increase
y to 1 and again we cycle through pixels
0 to 500 horizontally
then we increase y to 2 and we cycle
through the entire x-coordinate of
pixels again
we will do this 706 times because our
image is 706 pixels high
which means it contains 706 rows of
horizontal pixels
the code will look like this we will use
nested for loops which means loop inside
of another loop
the outer loop will represent vertical y
coordinate so it will run
706 times because our image is 706
pixels high
which means we have 706 rows of pixels
we will start with top row 0 and go all
the way down to row 706
on the bottom for each row of pixels in
the image
i will create an array called row it
will hold our pixel data for each of the
rows
for every one of these rows we enter the
inner loop
and index of this in loop will
correspond to horizontal x-coordinate
of pixel within the image starting from
x-coordinate 0
and going to the right until we reach
pixel 500
because our image is 500 pixels wide
then we just exit the inner loop
increase y
by one therefore jump in to the next row
and going through the horizontal pixels
from left to right
from zero to 500 again i'm not sure if
i'm over explaining this
or if you need me to explain it more let
me know in the comments please
i'm just trying to make it accessible
for beginners as well
so now we have two nested for loops that
work together to cycle through every
single pixel in the image
for each individual pixel i want to read
its color values so here
i will create a temporary variables for
red green and blue
red for each pixel will be pixels
variable from line 11
dot data which is this data object here
with 1 million
and twelve thousand elements where we
know each four elements
represent red green blue and alpha of
one pixel
there are many ways we can skip array
index by four i will use this formula
i'm sure there is easier way to do this
let me know in the comments
the first part that says y times 4 times
pixel's width
just keeps track of overall number of
array elements from previous rows
and the second part that says x times 4
just adds the items from the current row
to it
so the final number we get is array
position of red value
for pixel with this y-coordinate and
this
x-coordinate this is not programming
anymore this is more like advanced logic
and visualization i wish i had more
visual tools to show you better
what's going on i will try to come up
with something for future tutorials
in the meantime let's just finish this
once we know what index red color value
is
it's easy to get green blue and alpha
because we know that this data array
is organized in a way where red is
followed by green which is followed by
blue
and alpha since i know this i know that
green
is whatever red is plus one
and blue is position of right in pixels
array
plus 2. so now i have calculated
red green and blue of pixels at this
vertical y coordinate
and this horizontal x coordinate
i could just add them together and
divide them by 3 to get their average
value which is the same technique we
used to
turn image into grayscale in the
previous episode for beginners
link in the video description there is a
strange thing about human eye that we
don't perceive
red green and blue the same the same
amount of
red is not the same brightness as the
same amount of blue
when perceived by human eye we can
create a simple utility function
that will take red green and blue value
we just calculated for each pixel
it will adjust them by different amount
based on human brightness perception and
it will return a single number
representing relative brightness of that
pixel
custom function called for example
calculate relative
brightness it will expect three
arguments red
green and blue we calculated on lines 20
21 and 22.
it will just straight up return a number
calculated by following formula
i found this formula online we don't
have to fully understand it because all
it does
it adjusts red green and blue by
different amounts
to make up for the fact that the human
eye doesn't perceive
these three colors the same when it
comes to their relative brightness
this is just for fun to make it more
visually accurate i guess
as i said this formula could have been a
simple other red plus green
plus blue divided by 3 to get average
and it would work as well
of course then you have to adjust the
rest of the code like particle falling
speed
based on the range of numbers this would
return
up on line 23 i create a variable called
brightness
thanks to javascript principle called
hoisting i can call my custom calculate
relative brightness function i declared
on line 27
up here on line 23 before that function
is declared
hosting allows us to do that it expects
three arguments so i pass it right
i calculated here on line 20. this
simply is a reference to index in pixels
array
as we cycle through it so for example
for this pixel
red would be zero green would be zero
and blue would be zero so brightness
is zero as well
i create a constant variable called cell
and i set it equal to an array
i give it property called cell
brightness and i set it equal to
brightness variable from line 23
here inside the cell array you could
also create another property called
cell color and create rgb color
declaration
where you concatenate red green and blue
and you save this pixel's actual color
so we can use it in fill style on draw
method for that particle
that way you can persist original colors
of the image
more on that later so we calculated
relative brightness of pixel
of this vertical y and this horizontal x
coordinate
and saved it in a custom array i call
cell i take row variable from line 18
and i push
cell from line 24 to that array we will
create this cell array for every pixel
in every row
so row variable from line 18 will be
created
times because outside for loop will run
for every row of our image
which is 706 pixels high
and inside of each of these 706 rows we
create cell array here on line 24.
we will have 500 cells for each row
because our image is 500 pixels wide
each cell holds relative brightness
value for each individual pixel in the
image
so every time the loop is done and we
pushed 500 cells into that row we take
the entire row from line 18 and push it
into mapped image array from line 16.
that way when all these loops have run
we have mapped image array with 706 row
arrays
inside of each of these row arrays there
are 500 cell arrays
each cell array from line 24 represents
one pixel in the image
we did it we cycled through pixels
variable from line 11
we took that image data and created our
own array called mapped image that
contains brightness values for each
pixel on canvas
if i consolidate mapped image you see
706
items these are the raw arrays from line
18. each one holds 500 cell elements
from line 24 and each cell is an array
that contains only one element
that is this cell brightness property
that contains
relative brightness of each pixel we
calculated we will get a lot of zeros as
cell brightness value because there are
large black areas around my image
but if i keep looking i will be able to
find other values here as well
see now i just need to take this
information about brightness
i stored in mapped image variable and
somehow make particles fall
at different speeds based on that first
of all
we need to navigate in indexes of that
array based on particles current x and y
coordinates
since array index has to be integer
whole number with no decimal points here
on line 48 and 49
inside particles class constructor i
create position 1 and position 2 custom
variables
that will simply round down this dot x
and this.y
making sure that these numbers don't
have decimal points
i also need to put these values here
inside update method to make sure
every time we update x and y position
these values
stay rounded down as whole numbers as
integers
now the main trick of how this entire
effect works i will adjust
this dot speed from line 45 i will
literally take values from my custom
mapped image array
and since we organized pixel data in the
array to the same width and height as
our canvas
using our nested for loops i pull value
from a mapped image array based on
particles current x and y position
this dot position 1 corresponds to
particles current
vertical y coordinate as we declared on
line 52
and adding it as index like this on line
54
will access custom row array in mapped
image
which has the same vertical y position
as the particle currently has
then we go one level deeper inside map
image array to access horizontal x
position
i called these arrays cells if you
remember
and they contain only one property
called cell brightness so that's array
position 0.
so what we have here is mapped image
custom row array from line 18
custom cell array from line 24 and it
has only one element
i called cell brightness from line 25 so
position in this array is
zero and since outer loop that created
mapped image on line 17
matches height of canvas and in a loop
from line 19
matches canvas width the brightness
information held in mapped image will
correspond exactly with our image
let me show you i appreciate this might
be hard to follow and imagine what's
going on at first if you can't follow
what i'm explaining here with no
problems congratulations you are not in
majority of us
it took me a while to realize how this
works to create a full mental picture
i bet some of you will be able to tell
me there is a much simpler way to do
this and i am looking forward to these
comments
i've learned a lot from your comments
already so please keep them coming
so here on line 54 i take speed from
line 45
and i assign it to brightness value of
that area in the original image
then i create a custom variable let's
call it movement for example
relative brightness we calculated
earlier and which is now reflected in
this dot speed because of line 54
with a small number between 0 and 2.5
approximately
i think since i want dark particles that
have brightness close to zero
move very fast and i want light
particles with relative brightness
close to 2.5 to move very slow i flip it
by saying 2.5 which is the maximum minus
this dot speed and i also want to
randomize it a bit
so if we have a large area of particles
with the same color
they still don't move exactly the same
speed to do that
i just do plus this dot velocity from
line 46
now here on line 57 i say this dot y
plus equals movement
and we should be able to see that
particles react to image now
velocity on line 46 is too high let's
change it
to random number between 0 and 0.5
perfect important part of this effect is
that
the faster the particles move the more
transparent they are
on line 77 inside animate i remove the
image so it's not been redrawn over and
over
you can see we are getting something
nice on canvas already
code between lines 77 and 79 just
creates a semi-transparent rectangle
that is being drawn on canvas over and
over
given particles fade in trails once we
draw it i want global alpha to increase
to let's say 0.2 and here inside for
loop
that cycles through all particles for
every animation frame
before we actually draw the particle i
will adjust global alpha
for that particle to be equal to
particle's speed
property
that's a bit too much let's half it
speed times
0.5
up on line 10 on the first page load i
draw the original image on canvas using
built-in html canvas draw image method
on line 11 i call get image data on it
to get information about all its pixels
and i save it to my custom pixels
variable
at that point i don't need the image
anymore so i just clear canvas
deleting the original image when i do
this we will never see that image at all
it will be drawn analyzed and deleted
when page loads are very fast
there are a lot of moving parts and many
ways to customize this effect you can
try to tweak some values and see what it
does
idea for this effect came from this
brilliant code pen
link in the video description luis also
has many other interesting animations on
there
you can follow him if you want there is
a lot of code in that code pen
today we wrote our own version line by
line using just plain vanilla javascript
and we explained exactly what's going on
on each line of code
i hope it gave you some value and
brought you one step closer to becoming
a master of web animation
now you should be able to understand it
and tweak it to make your own variations
or maybe even build on it and create
something completely new
now we know how to make black and white
pixel rain how about we take it to the
next level
we will add colors give particles a
different movement patterns and shapes
experiment with filters blend modes
gradients
and i will try to create fire effect
let's see what comes out of that
click like please
in the previous episode we built this
black and white pixel rain effect
step by step completely from scratch and
i explained how everything works
let's just have a play with it and
create variations using different
javascript tools and techniques
let's see what comes out of that in
style css i move the canvas slightly
more upwards
first of all i will quickly swap to a
different image we are using data string
that contains
all image data to replace it i just
enable word drop in my code editor
i select beginning of the string then i
scroll all the way to the end
and on my windows pc using vs code
editor
when i hold down shift key and click
here
left click it will highlight all the
code in between
i delete it and replace it with a
different image when replacing images in
your projects make sure canvas width and
canvas height on lines 7 and 8
as well as install css file is updated
to much dimensions of the new image you
are using
in my case i made sure the new image is
the same size as the old one
i gave you a challenge last time instead
of black and white effect
to try and dynamically assign colors of
the original image
to the particles as they flow over areas
with different colors
solution is very simple we already
calculated red green and blue here
anyway to get our brightness
so i just create another property in
custom cell array
called cell color and i concatenate
string
rgb plus right
plus comma plus green
plus comma plus blue plus closing
bracket
now this little cell array we create for
each pixel contains
two values relative brightness and
original color
to use this color all i need to do is go
down here
to draw method on particle class and on
line 67
instead of setting fill style to white i
set it to this new color property
inside cell array same as we do with
brightness on line 56
i go down two levels inside my custom
mapped image array
and inside cell array i see that cell
brightness is the first property
so index 0 and cell color
is index 1. down here on line 67
i set the last index to 1 and here we go
we are drawing in color that was easy
let's play with particle movement now we
will face a weird bug here
i will tell you why it's happening and i
will show you easy way to fix it
when i increase vertical y value
particles fall down
what if at the same time i increase
horizontal x position
oh here is the bug one of our particles
moved outside the canvas area
and because of lines 56 and 68
javascript doesn't have indexes for
these coordinates in mapped image array
and everything breaks in this case i can
fix it by resetting x and y correctly
on line 61 if vertical y position
reaches bottom of canvas i set it back
to 0
and i randomize x horizontally i will
also check when horizontal x position is
more than canvas width
and i set x back to 0 and randomize y
vertically this solves the bug we are
getting when particles move outside the
canvas area
but for the next effect i want to use
trigonometry
and make particles move in waves i won't
be able to make sure particles never
reach outside of canvas area
when we have complex flowing movement
like that so i will have to fix that
back in a different way
by the way you can also change angle at
which particles fall by adjusting lines
59 and 60
like this first let's try to apply some
fluctuation to particles movement
and let's see what happens on line 52
inside particle class constructor i
create
this dot angle property this will be
individual for each particle
and the reason i make separate angle for
each particle
is because i want each particle to
fluctuate
at different speed depending on the
brightness of the underlying area
just like we did with movement speed
earlier let me show you how
at first i will increase this.angle
inside update method for each particle
by one for every frame
so far all particles will have identical
motion
i take that angle value and i pass it to
trigonometry function
called math.sine this will just take the
angle value
and periodically run it between plus 1
and -1 over and over which will give us
fluctuating movement
immediately when i do it i will get an
error it is because particles wiggle now
and on line 61 i say this.y is movement
plus
this wiggle created by math.sine the
problem is this
imagine this particle is all the way to
the bottom edge and method sign is added
to that position on line
61 making the particle move further down
outside the canvas area in reset check
on line
63 particles this dot y is not past the
bottom edge of canvas yet so it will not
reset y to zero
but because we added mod.sign to it on
line 61
particle's actual coordinate is outside
canvas
normally that wouldn't be a problem but
here on line 57 i calculate speed of
particles
based on their coordinates because each
set of coordinates has different
underlying brightness and the speed
depends on that
my mapped image array on line 57 has
only values for actual image dimensions
so when i ask it
to access vertical index 710
when my original image was only 700
pixels tall
this index in mapped image array doesn't
exist
in this case javascript will not know
what to do and the entire animation will
stop
in console log you will see something
like this cannot read property
some number of undefined because we are
asking for index
in mapped image array outside the canvas
area
and mapped image array is set exactly to
match canvas dimensions as we explained
in the last episode
so this index in that array doesn't
exist
so on line 57 we only want to assign a
new speed value if particle is within
canvas so that we can check for
brightness of underlying area
by accessing associated indexes and
mapped
image array i will just simply do an if
statement here
if vertical y position is within canvas
area
this.position1 and at the same time
horizontal x position is not undefined
as well
only then assign new value to this dot
speed
otherwise just use all the distort speed
value that was assigned in previous
frames
that's fixed but i get another error on
line 76
the same issue here we are asking for
color of the original image
but particle is currently outside canvas
area so mapped image array
doesn't have color data for this
position
i do exactly the same fix if statement
only if horizontal
and vertical position have corresponding
indexes in mapped image array
and are not undefined only then change
fill style to new color
otherwise fill style will just stay the
same color from the previous frame
problem solved now we can give particles
any crazy movement and the effect will
not break
the wiggle is barely noticeable let's
make particles spin around properly
i also add circular movement to this dot
x
i change sine to cosine on line 61
angle is increased by one per frame of
animation way too fast
look what happens when i slow it down we
can actually see the circle movement now
but all particles are moving in the same
rhythm i
put angle property on particle class
constructor on line 52 which means
each particle has its own individual
angle value
if i wanted all particles to move the
same like this angle could have been a
global variable and it would have saved
javascript a lot of calculation
since we have separate angle for each
particle let's make each particle
spin around based on its distort speed
property
which is individually calculated on line
58 based on brightness of the underlying
area
meaning that the dark areas of our image
will create different
circular patterns than light areas
this dot speed is too fast let's divide
it by 10.
interesting making it even smaller
number will really show off what's going
on because particles move slower over
light areas just because they spend more
time
in there they are more likely to make a
complete spin and it kind of looks in
some places like particles are actually
bouncing off the light areas in the
image
how about we create our own spectrum
that's also very easy
up on line 9 i create a constant
variable called gradient 1 and i set it
equal to ctx
create linear gradient this is a built
in canvas method
it expects four arguments two sets of
coordinates
these determine direction of the
gradient imagine drawing a line between
them to see the direction
i want my gradient to go from top left
corner coordinate 0
0 to bottom right corner coordinates
canvas width canvas height
i take this gradient one variable i just
created and i call at color stop built
in
method on it it expects two arguments
position between 0 and 1 and color we
want at that position
i will just speed this up and make some
color stops to create rainbow
my color stops will be at 20 30 40
50 60 70 and 80 percent and the colors
will be for example pink
red orange yellow green turquoise
and violet
to apply this i can simply go down to
line 84
i disable colors from the original image
for now
and i set fill style to gradient one
variable we just created
upon line 9 you can change these
coordinates to change angle
of your gradient
what if i want size of particles to be
small in dark areas
and larger in bright areas very simple
to do as well
i go down to line 70 inside update
method and i set this dot size
to this dot speed as speed already
depends on brightness anyway
how about speed times 2 maybe speed
times 1.5
let's comment outline 88 and uncomment
this to get
original colors
how about instead of filled circles we
use stroked rectangles
this works but we didn't set our stroke
style so it defaults to black
i just added here on line 87
the rectangles are too small maybe size
times five
how about size times three
interesting you can put any drawing code
here to represent each particle
even more complex shapes or image from a
sprite sheet like we do in game dev
videos for example if you use more
complex particle shapes you have to
consider the number of particles
that make up our effect it might be a
lot for our computer to handle
and draw all these complex shapes let's
try to replace particles with letters
for example with capital m that seems to
run okay even though replacing circle
with letter is a bit more demanding on
performance
how about i create a constant variable
called letters and i set it equal to an
array
the array will contain some letters for
example we can spell mandalorian
or let's just do n a n
then down here in particle class
constructor i create a new property
and each particle when it is created
will be assigned one of these letters
randomly
i do that by saying this.letter equals
letters array
i just created and index will be a
random number between
0 and letter's length this will give us
numbers with decimal points but array
has only indexes 0
1 and 2 because i have 3 elements in my
letters array
to make sure we only get integers whole
numbers without decimal points i wrap it
in math.floor which will round it down
to the nearest integer
now i can take this new letter property
i just created
and in draw method on line 95 inside
fill text
instead of hard-coded letter m i pass it
this dot letter
now our particles are random letter from
that array
up on line 25 i reduce the number of
particles so that we can actually make
up individual letters better
inside animation loop i comment out line
12 that changes particles opacity based
on their movement speed
and i set everything to full opacity
global alpha equals
to 1. this looks pretty cool
what if i want only certain percentage
of my particles to be letters and the
rest
regular circles how do i control that i
can for example create this.random
property on particle class constructor
and i just set it the math at random
like this
math random code like this returns a
random small number between 0
and 1. each particle gets assigned a
different random number
at the point when the constructor gets
called and that particle is created
on line 96 inside our custom draw method
on particle class i can say if this dot
random
is less than 0.1 which should roughly be
in 10 percent
of the cases then draw particle
as text as one of the letters from
letters array
else draw it as a circle
this way you can control different
percentages of particles and give them
different properties based on that
you can do anything here if i change 0.1
to 0.5
now approximately 50 of my particles
should appear as letters
i can use ctx font to set text size and
font family let's try 20 pixels aerial
i can tweak the amount of text particles
by tweaking if statement on line 97
i can replace text with stroke
rectangles
make them larger okay back to the
circles
this effect also works with global
composite operation property where you
can blend particles
together in different ways i like when
particles flow from one side and wash
over the image
until now it only ever happened on the
first page load
if i set start in x or y position to
edge of canvas
what if i want particles to come in
waves and periodically create this
splash movement
let's create a variable that will switch
between two values
i will call it for example switch oh no
that's a reserved word in javascript
let's do switcher
and another one called counter both will
be let variables because i will be
changing their values
i create set interval that takes two
arguments
callback function to run and how often
in milliseconds to run it
i want it to run every 500 milliseconds
every time it runs i increase counter
plus 1
and now i can use that to set periodic
events
in my code base i say if counter modulus
12 is equal to 0
modulus operator percentage symbol is
also called
remainder operator this if statement
means if counter value
is divisible by 12 with a remainder of 0
which means as counter increases by 1
every 500 milliseconds
this if statement will be true at 0 12
24 36 and so on every time counter
variables from line 20 increases by 12
set switcher variable from line 19 to
its opposite value
switcher times equals -1
at first switcher is set to 1 so 1
times -1 is -1 then it runs again
switcher is minus 1 so minus 1 times
minus 1 is plus 1.
it will just repeat and switch between
plus 1 and -1 over and over
every 12 cycles of this interval
on line 84 inside custom update method
on particle class
i can say if switcher is plus 1
do something else
do something else
let me show you what global composite
operation does
i can set it for example to soft light
oh i actually misspelled it it's
supposed to be operation
you can see these values control
compositing or blending mode operations
on canvas
they can blend shapes adjust contrast
hue brightness
and other properties of canvas giving us
different effects
there are over 20 different values soft
light affects how light and dark is
displayed
luminosity preserves luma or brightness
of the top layer
and it also preserves you and chroma of
the bottom layer
from their official descriptions it's
really hard to guess what will the final
result look like
so i just try and see what happens some
of them like source out might freeze
your browser because
what it does is performance intensive
when you have so many particles
like we do in this effect so be careful
i can use my custom switcher variable to
switch between two different blend modes
periodically
just for fun combining two specific ones
might create something interesting
let's swap between luminosity and
lighter
at the same time i say if counter
modulus 10 is 0
every 10 cycles of counter variable set
x
and y to zero so particles splash
over the canvas over and over
what if i randomize it this way
let's reset y to zero and leave x as a
random number
now the image automatically switches
between two different blend modes
and particles periodically reset so they
can flow over the image
in a wave again
let's comment out this bit
i can swap sine and cosine on lines 94
and 96
this will affect the circular path
particles take
tweaking anything on these lines will
affect particle movement in a major way
i can for example make particles move
upwards
if i do that i need to adjust reset
check on line 96
i'm just playing with the reset checks
trying to get it right
on line 67 i can change particle size
actually no because i am overriding it
on line 82 because i wanted particle
size to be relative to particle's
current speed
i'm trying to build a fire effect now i
need to get the right size here
install css i apply css filters
i will use blur 2 pixels and then i
sharpen it with contrast
contrast is just a number without pixels
adjustment size on line 85 will affect
how the fire looks like
what variations can you come up with do
you have any ideas how to tweak this
effect and create something interesting
let me know we can also use pixel array
to turn text into particles
in the next creative coding experiment i
will show you how to create
interactive particle text effect in
three steps
first i will create a set of particles
randomly spread around canvas
we will give them some physics i will
try to give their movement some
elasticity and physics
by applying forces of friction and
acceleration when they interact with
mouse
then in the next step i will write some
text on canvas
i will scan it with get image data and i
will make particles
take shape of these letters as the final
third step
i will apply constellations effect that
was made famous by particles.js library
but i will use no libraries we will
write all the code using just plain
vanilla javascript to achieve
constellations effect we just have to
calculate distance between each particle
and connect particles that are close
enough to each other with lines
i think this effect looks really good
what do you think let me know in the
comments
if you get stuck and need some help feel
free to reach out to me on twitter or
message me somewhere on my youtube
channel
i do a lot of creative coding
experiments canvas animations and game
development
click like please in index.html i'll
link css stylesheet
create html5 canvas element with an id
of canvas1
and ilinkscript.js file which will
contain all javascript logic
in style css i just do the basic reset
to make sure the page appears the same
in all browsers
ask the risk selector to target all
elements on the page
and i set margin to 0 padding 0 and book
size into border box border box means
that elements padding and border will be
included in its total width and height
on the body element i set overflow to
hidden
to hide potential scroll bars and give
it black background
i choose to place the background on the
body element instead on the canvas
because this will allow us to use liquid
or distortion svg filters if we choose
to
especially liquid filter only works if
canvas background is transparent
canvas will have position absolute job 0
left 0
everything else will be done with the
javascript in script.js file
i create a variable i call canvas and i
set it equal to document
getelementbyid canvas1
ctx shortcut for context is equal to
canvasgetcontext2d
doing this will create a built-in
context object that contains all kinds
of 2d drawing methods that
come built in in any browser using
canvas api
now i can call all of them using our ctx
variable
canvas width is the window in a width
and canvas height is the window in a
height
this will make sure the canvas covers
the entire browser window
i create a variable called particle
array and i set it equal to an empty
array
this will contain all our particle
objects that each contains
information like size color and
coordinates
and we will pull this information from
here to draw them on canvas
before we do that i will write some code
to handle mouse interactions
i create a custom variable i call for
example mouse
and i set it equal to javascript object
by using curly brackets like this
i give this custom object some
properties x will be the current
position of mouse on horizontal x-axis
y will be positioned on the vertical y
axis
radius will be size of a circle area
around the mouse
within which the particles react to
mouse
i create an event listener it takes two
attributes
type of event to listen for and call
back function to run
every time that particular event occurs
i want to listen for mouse move event
and every time user moves the mouse
within the browser window i want to run
the following code
callback function on event listener has
one special thing about it
it has access to built-in object that
contains all different details about the
event that is occurring
all i need here are x and y coordinates
of the event so that i can assign them
dynamically to our customer mouse object
i created on line 8.
i need to assign them to the custom
object to pull that coordinate
information
outside of event listener so i can use
this information
all over our application so as an
argument
to the callback function i write down
event some people just put letter e here
it doesn't really matter
javascript knows this variable will
stand for that built-in event object and
will let you use it
whatever you call it here as long as you
refer to it using the same variable name
later on so inside the callback function
i set mousex which is property declared
on line 9
to event.x and mouse y to event.y
if you console.log event inside this
event listener you will notice it is
quite similar to our custom mouse object
on line 9.
the only difference is that it contains
many more properties and it is only
available inside an event listener
that's why i am pulling the information
from it here and sending it outside to
our customer mouse object
so that mouse coordinates are available
all over our application
wherever i might need them later on
i can check if it works by console login
mouse x and mouse y
now if i move mouse over the canvas with
open console
i can see we are getting values great
this is one of my favorite ways to
handle mouse input
it is useful for everything from
generative art website interactions to
games
now let's draw some text on canvas ctx
font properties sets the current font
properties for text context on the
canvas
you can also set bold or italic here if
you want
then you put size and the last attribute
will be font family
let's just try 30 pixels verdana for
start
now i call ctx filtex method
which will just draw and fill text on
canvas
it expects at least three attributes the
first one is the text we want to write
i just put capital letter a for now the
second one is
x coordinate on canvas where you want to
draw that text
the third attribute is y coordinate
there is also
an optional fourth attribute where you
can define max width of the text in
pixels
we will leave it empty for now but keep
that in mind
by default the text will be black unless
you set it to any other color using fill
style property
so i call ctx fill style method and set
it to white
now we can see we are drawing our text
at specified coordinates
i can change it by adjusting its size on
line 21
or its position on line 22.
now what i want to do is to scan a small
area of canvas around the white letter a
analyze the pixels filter out pixels
with no opacity
because that's where the text is and
only save those pixels that are not
transparent
into our particles array more
specifically i want to save their x and
y coordinates
and i can also save their color values
if i want to
that way we can replicate the shape of
letter with particles
by using x and y coordinates of each
pixel as coordinates for our particles
remember that the black background is on
body element so canvas is completely
transparent with only letter a
in white color to do this i just use
another canvas method called
get image data we used it before to turn
image into particles in one of my
all-time most popular videos
and we will do something similar today
with text official definition of this
method is that it returns
image data object representing the
underlying pixel data of a specified
portion
of the canvas if i want to say it much
simpler
you give this method four coordinates
for rectangular area
somewhere on canvas it scans that area
pixel by pixel
and it saves coordinates and color
information for each pixel
inside of a huge data array
since we know how the data is organized
we can easily extract that information
and use it for anything we want
so i create a variable i call for
example data
and i set it equal to ctx.getimagedata
and i pass it for attributes to tell it
what part of canvas we want to scan
i want to start from top left corner so
coordinate 0 0
and i want to scan just small bit let's
say square
of 100 x 100 pixels so i pass it with
100
height 100 which is somewhere around
here
if i want to visualize the area we
scanned i can just stroke white
rectangle there so we can see
stroke style set to white stroke
rectangle and i pass it the same area i
passed
to get image data method on line 25
see this is the area we will be scanning
so our data variable on line 25
will contain array with coordinates and
color information for each pixel
inside this small square okay let's
delete this it was just so we can
visualize what's going on
now i need a way to create many similar
particles that will each represent one
interactive dot in our final effect
for that i will use javascript class i
call it particle with capital p
each class has one mandatory method
called a constructor
constructor will run just once for each
particle
it will create a new blank object and
assign it properties and values based on
information i will declare inside of it
it will serve as a blueprint our
constructor will expect just two
attributes
x and y coordinates which will be
different for each particle
and we will pass them to the constructor
from the outside to make it spell out
our letters for the final effect
inside i just say this dot x property on
a new blank object you are creating is
equal to x
we passed as an attribute same for
vertical y coordinate
we will have other properties but these
will be set or randomized here inside
the constructor we don't need to add
them
from the outside so we don't need to
pass them as arguments on
line 26 this dot size will be radius of
each circle particle
so let's try for example 3 pixels
i will also set this to base x and set
it to this dot x
and this dot base y and set it to this
dot
y base x and base y properties will hold
the initial position for each particle
from the first time they appeared the
reason for that is that we will be
moving and pushing the particles around
by changing their this dot x and this.y
properties
but i want each particle to remember
where it came from so it can return to
its original position when mouse
interaction ends
also i choose to set this.basex equal to
this
dot x property from line 27 instead of
setting it
to x attribute passed on line 26
it will be the same but doing this will
allow me to modify the starting position
of this dot x on line 27
like this and our base x variable will
remember
that modified state it can be used for
interesting distortion effects
not sure if we do it today but there is
no harm if we set up our code base for
it anyway
distal density will be a random number
between
1 and 30. it will determine how heavy
our particles are
and how fast they move away from the
mouse i want each particle to move
slightly different speeds to simulate
some
physics so now the blueprint is complete
we will also need a custom draw method
each of our particles will have access
to it because it will be sitting on the
particle class this method will just
take x and y and radius
from the constructor and draw a circle
there representing our particle
i set fill style to white we are drawing
a circle on canvas so i need to use ctx
begin path method
think of it as pencil touching down on
canvas to start drawing
i call canvas arc method and i pass it
this dot x and this dot y coordinates
this dot size will be radius of the
circle start angle will be 0
and end angle will be math.pi times 2
which is value in radians
that represents that actually converts
to 360 degrees so we have just drawn a
circular path
from 0 to 360 degrees which is a full
circle
if you change start angle and end angle
values here you can use arc method to
create half circle or even many other
shapes
i call close path and ctx fill to fill
the path with white color
now i create another custom function i
call init
its job is to take particle class we
just created
and call it many times the fill particle
array with randomized particle objects
first i will set particle array to an
empty array in case it's not
empty at the moment now i call push
method which will take whatever we pass
to it
and pushes that to the end of the array
we call it on
i pass it new particle the new keyword
is a special command in javascript
it will call constructor of its
associated class
in our case it will go up to line 26
create one new blank object and give it
values and properties as described in
the blueprint between lines 27
and 32. on the line 26 we can see our
constructor expects x and y coordinates
as attributes so here on line 45
i pass it 50 50 as coordinates for now
now i call init to push one particle
into the array
i count lock particle array to see if it
works
i need to comment outline 17 that's
still log in our mouse position
yes now i can see the array contains one
particle
i can add another one at coordinates 80
and 50.
and now we have two particles in our
array
i create a custom function i call
animate which will handle
animation loop first i call ctx clear
rectangle and pass it canvas dimensions
to clear the entire canvas between every
frame of animation
i create a for loop that will cycle
through the entire particles array and
for each particle object inside
that array it will call its custom draw
method we declared on line 34.
the last thing i need to do is to call
requestanimationframe and pass it
animate
the name of its parent function this way
animate will run all of its code
and it will call itself again over and
over
create an animation loop so far i have
just declared animate i also need to
call it
to start our animation loop
it is not drawing our particles and in
console i can see we have error on line
37 where i misspelled arc
fixed now we are drawing two particles
as i declare them on line 45 and 46.
i can change their x and y coordinates
and you can see they will move around as
i change
these values so instead of calling the
particles individually like this i
create a for loop
that will run for example 10 times
i comment out the two individual
particles and inside the for loop i do
the same thing
particle array push and i pass it new
particle
it expects x and y coordinates so i will
create a temporary x variable
its only job is to generate random
number between 0 and 500
i do the same for y coordinate
now i call new particle and i pass it
temporary x and y variables i have just
created on line 46 and 47.
you can see we are drawing 10 randomized
particles because for loop
on line 45 runs 10 times
if i want the particles to be randomly
spread all around the canvas i can
set x to a random number between 0 and
canvas width
and temporary y variable to a random
number between 0 and canvas height
now our entire canvas is covered with
particles i increase the amount
of particles to let's try 500.
well done we have base structure for our
generative art project in place
first we declare global variables then
created object to store mouse
coordinates
then on line 25 we create a blueprint
that will be used to create particles
function init online 43 will use that
blueprint to fill particle array with
particle objects
and lastly we created animation loop on
line 56 which is running over and over
and redrawing our canvas for every frame
even though it looks static now we are
actually drawing the same thing over and
over
let's make it move now
on line 35 i can change color let's try
red
i create another custom method i call
update its job is to calculate distance
between current mouse position and
current particle position
if they are close enough i want
particles to be pushed away from the
mouse
now i will show you how to calculate the
distance between two points this can be
used for creative coding and it is also
very useful for games
let's calculate distance between two
points on the horizontal x-axis
first i will call this variable dx
it is simply the difference between
their position on x-axis
let's say if mouse position x was 50 and
particle position x was 30
dx will be 50 minus 30 which is 20.
simple is just the difference same for
dui which is the difference between
position of two elements we are
comparing vertically
we are comparing mouse against all
particles one by one
so d y is mouse dot y minus this
dot y this dot y stands for each
individual particle
as we cycle through all of them one by
one
imagine these two values we have just
calculated create a right angle triangle
between mouse and particle we have dx
side
we have a d y side of the triangle
and we know there is a right angle
between them so 90 degrees
we can get distance between these two
points by calculating the longest side
of the triangle
opposite to the right angle it is also
called hypotenuse
there is a built-in method hypotenuse
method in javascript but today i will
just use
pythagoras theorem to calculate it
we have two sides of right angle
triangle and we know
there is a 90 degree angle between them
we need to calculate the third side and
that will be the distance between two
points
which is what we need formula is
mod square root dx times dx plus dy
times
dy which also is which is the same thing
as mod square root dx squared plus dy
squared
since this is calculated inside update
method on particle object
each particle will always be aware of
how far away it is from a mouse
so here i can say if distance between
particle and mouse is less than 500
run this code if particles are closer to
mouse than 500 i will set their size to
50 pixels
else digital size will return back to 3
which is the original value
we declared on line 29 to run this code
i need to go inside animation loop and
on line 68
inside for loop that cycles through the
entire particles array for every frame
of animation
the same way i call draw method for
every particle
i will also call update the method we
have just created
and you see it works now i can change
the distance particles react to mouse
here on line 45
i can also create more particles on line
55.
now you can see the distance is being
correctly calculated and we have a nice
boilerplate for creative particle effect
we can do so many things now maybe if
you want before we continue you can save
and copy this code base
in a different folder and experiment
with it later on it's always good to
have the base setup stored away
somewhere
and now you can just focus on your
experiments
so what i want to do now is for
particles that are close to mouse
to start moving away from it i want them
to move
from the center point of the circle
towards the edge
i also want particles to move at
different speeds depending on their
weight
we defined earlier when we assigned this
density property
inside particle class constructor and
third thing i want to happen is for
particles to move
fast if they are close to mouse but
gradually slow down
the closer they are to the outer edge of
circular interaction area
until they reach speed of zero when they
touch the outer edge
basically we will introduce some basic
physics to particle movement
this might sound like a complicated
thing to do with code but i will show
you a nice calculation
that can do all of this for us i create
a variable i call force direction x
and i set it equal to dx divided by
distance
force direction y will be d y divided by
distance
on line 48 if particles are closer to
the mouse than 300 pixels
i will add force direction x to
particles current x position
and force direction y to particles
current y
position this will just make them slowly
move towards the mouse
if i multiply these values by let's say
3
it will make the movement faster
now i want to set a distance past which
particle's movement speed is zero
so i create another variable i call it
max distance
it will be equal to mouse.radius we
declared on line 11.
any particle that is more distant from
the current mouse position than this
will stop
moving this calculation i'm about to do
takes any range of numbers and converts
it to a range between 1 and
0. it will convert values between 0 and
max
distance into a range of 1 to 0
just so i can multiply values on line 51
and 52
by this number and get the particles to
slow down as the distance between them
and mouse increases until they reach
speed 0
as they reach the outer radius of
interaction's circle around the mouse
so i will call that variable for example
force
all i want to do now is to take number
range of 0 to 250
and convert it to number between 1 and 0
depending on where on range between
these two values the number is
0 is particle with a distance zero from
the mouse
so it will be touching the mouse i want
this number to be converted to one
so i can multiply current particle speed
by this which will make the particle
move at its
full speed the second side of that range
is number 250 which is represented
by max distance variable i want any
particle
that are further away from the mouse
than this to have speed 0
so they stop moving let's say there is a
particle halfway between
0 and 250 so this particle is roughly
halfway between these values
it is 125 pixels away from the mouse
at that point i want that particle to be
moving at 50
speed so i need force variable to be
equal to 0.5 at that point
if i multiply current speed times 0.5
it will move at 50 speed when particle
reaches 80 percent towards the outer
edge of interaction circle
i want it to move at 20 speed so i want
force to be 0.2
when particle is at 90 percent i want it
to be moving only at 10 percent of its
original speed
and so on to get this behavior i need to
convert range between 0 and 250
or whatever max distance variable is on
line 48
i want to convert this range to a
smaller range between 1 and 0.
once i have that value i will multiply
it times particle speed
and it will cause particles to slow down
in proportions
to its current distance from the mouse
you can already see the calculation
i say max distance minus current
distance to see how far particle
currently is from the max distance area
and once i have that value i divide it
by max distance again
which will tell me what proportion of
max distance it is quick example
if max distance is 100 pixels and
particles current distance from mouse
was
20 pixels max distance minus current
distance would be 80.
then 80 divided by 100 is 0.8
so our force would be 0.8
basically anything multiplied times 0.8
is 20 percent less so it will slow our
particle down by 20 percent
i'm not sure if this is just me or this
is quite difficult
mathematical operation to understand it
took me a very long time to work this
out
i will get back to this again and try to
explain it better next time we use it
let me know in the comments if it's
unclear and we can talk about it
so now i have the force which is the
multiplier that will be slowing
particles down as they get further away
from the mouse
i create a variable called direction x
which will combine all factors
that play a role in particle's movement
speed
direction x is equal to force direction
x on line
46 times force we just calculated on
line 49
times this dot density from line 33.
i add this to density into the mix
because i also want individual particles
to have different
mass and i want that value to affect
their movement speed
it will look more natural otherwise all
particles will move the same speed as
particles around it
i do the same thing for direction y it
will be equal to force direction y
from line 47 times force which will
cause it to slow down as it moves
further away from the mouse
times distal density which is individual
and different for each particle
it's a random number between 1 and 31 as
we declared on line 33.
now on line 53 i say if distance is more
than mouse
radius which we declared on line 11
this dot x plus equals direction x
variable
from line 49 which combines all forces
that pull and drag on our particle
and i do the same thing for particles
word and i do the same thing for
particles
vertical y position this dot y plus
equals
direction y that was calculated on line
50.
it works yay particles move slow at
first and speed up as they get closer to
the mouse
the only problem is that i want them to
be pushed away so i change
plus sign to a minus sign on lines 53
and 54.
yes this is good and this is how you
implement quite complex physics with
javascript
i really like the movement and we will
enhance it even further by the way this
was the difficult part
i am not sure why i put mouse radius
here on line 17
inside mouse move event that's wrong i
will just delete that
radius is set to 450 pixels on line 11.
if you look closely particles move at
full speed when they are close to the
mouse
and when they get close to the outer
edge of interaction circle
they move slower and slower until they
stop
i can make them move faster by changing
density
let's try range between 50 and 200.
you can change the movement speed by
adjusting the range of values here on
line
31. so on line 51 i check if distance
between particles
and mouse is smaller than a certain
number
defined in mouse radius if it is i push
them away from the mouse
as you can see particles stay where they
are when mouse interaction ends
i would like them to return to their
original position
so here on line 54 in else statement i
say if this.x
is not equal to this.basex
basex is defined on line 29 and it
captures the initial position
of each particle so if this dot x has
changed because we pushed particles
around
and it is no longer equal to base x
which is particles original position
i will calculate distance between this
dot x which is particles current
position
and this dot base x which is particles
original position
on the horizontal x axis once i know the
difference
i can just return particle to its
original horizontal position
by saying this dot x minus equals dx
but to make particles move back slower i
say
dx divided by 10. it will eventually get
to its original position because this
code
is run for each frame of animation it
will just get there slower
also keep in mind we are currently
inside else statement which will be
entered only when particle is not close
enough to the mouse
so particles will only try to return to
their original position
once mouse moves far enough from them
so this way we corrected particles
horizontally
we can also correct them vertically
notice i don't do else if here
i just do simple if statement because i
don't want these to be mutually
exclusive
if particle has been displaced on x-axis
and also on y-axis
both of these statements will run for
each frame of animation
but also they can just run separately in
case on the x axis
or only y axis position needs to be
corrected to return particle
to its original position as we saved
this original position in base x and
base y variables
so if this dot y is not equal to this
dot base y
i calculate d y value distance y
value and i adjust this dot y by saying
minus
equals d y divided by 10.
by changing values on line 57 and 61 i
can change
how fast particles return to their
original position
so this all works at the moment we are
just spreading particles randomly around
the entire canvas area by calculating
random x and y values here on line 70
and passing them as attributes to
particles class constructor on line 72
how do we make the particles spell out
letters of text for that we use
data variable we declared on line 22.
here we call canvas image data
inbuilt method that takes four
attributes for a rectangular area of
canvas we want to scan
and it returns image data object that
contains information
like coordinates and color of the pixels
from that area on canvas
actually let me rename this variable for
clarity i rename
data to text coordinates so now this
variable
i called text coordinates holds whatever
get image data method returned
i go down inside our custom init
function which at the moment runs a for
loop
thousand times each time it runs it
calculates random x and y position
and creates a particle there i delete
all this code because we don't want our
particles to be randomly distributed
around canvas
we have just scanned the part of canvas
where we drew some text
and now i will filter that returned
object that resulted
from our scan and i will remove all
pixels with transparent background
leaving only data points for pixels that
contain color
which will be coordinates for particles
that make out our text effect
keep in mind that canvas is transparent
the black color you see
is set on body element so the only
pixels with color
are the actual letters let's go through
it step by step
i create a for loop and i will do
something a bit weird
instead of just declaring one variable
here as the first attribute i declare
two variables
i say let y equal 0 comma
y2 equals text coordinates dot height
as long as y is less than y2 y plus plus
this is almost a normal for loop two
things to mention here
first yes you can do this in javascript
you can put more than one variable
inside a for loop
also i could have just declared y2
variable outside the for loop and it
would work as well
second thing is that i say y2 equals
text coordinates height
text coordinates holds image data object
that resulted from a
scanning small portion of canvas using
get image data method
this object has height property in
pixels and since i want to scan the
resultant pixel data
line by line in this case row by row i
will run this for loop for every row of
pixel data we have
so we declared two variables and i say
as long as y
is less than y2 y plus plus don't
overthink this we just have two
variables
y will keep increasing until it reaches
the same value as y2
so our for loop will run until that
happens
so this is analyzing pixels row by row
each time i enter row of pixels i want
to go through them one by one from left
to right
so i create a nested for loop which
simply is loop
inside of another loop here i say let x
equal 0 x 2 is text coordinates width
which is simply just width of scanned
area in pixels
in this case we scanned rectangle 100
times 100 pixels as you can see on line
22.
so text coordinates height is 100
text coordinates width is 100 as well
this
outer for loop will run 100 times and
each time it runs it will run in a for
loop
100 times so we're gonna analyze
100 times 100 10 000 pixels i will
explain this further in a minute
back on line 70 i say as long as x is
less than
x2 x plus plus this nested for loop
might look complicated but all that's
happening here is i have a grid of 100
times 100 pixels
i go through them row by row or 969
each time i enter one row i go through
that row of pixels
one by one until i reach the end in this
case
pixel number 100 in for loop on line 70
will exit
we jump back to the outer loop on line
69
y will increase by 1 which will give us
another row
we enter in a loop on line 70 again and
go through all the pixels on that new
row
from pixel 1 to pixel 100 then we exit
the inner loop again
enter the outer loop increase y by one
which gives us
the next row and we do this for all 100
rows
analyzing all 100 pixels in each row
as i said we have 100 times 100 pixels
because that's the area of canvas i have
decided to scan using get image data
method online 22.
this nested loop basically allows us to
cycle through every pixels
in that hundred times 100 pixel area for
each pixel
i check if opacity of that pixel is more
than 128
i will explain what that means in a
second text coordinates custom variable
holds built-in
image data object that was returned by
get image data javascript method
this object has built-in data property
which is an array of elements
that represent pixels from the scanned
area of canvas
we can look inside by console login text
coordinates
in the console i can see it holds image
data object
if i open it you can see that object has
a data property
and this data property holds data array
with 40 000 elements
more down you can also see that it has
height and width properties
set to 100 which are the values we used
in the nested for loops
don't get scared this is very simple it
is not a normal array
if you look closely you will see this
type of array is called something
like uint8 clamped array
if i simplify this it's a special type
of array that can hold only numbers
and those numbers are limited to a
certain range you can say they are
clamped
each element in this array can only be a
number between
0 and 255
if you work with html and css you have
seen rgba color declaration which looks
like this
any color can be created by combining
different amounts of red
green and blue and the range for each
color
is from 0 to 255. one weird thing about
this clamped array is that it also
handles alpha or opacity this way
so 0 alpha is invisible 255 alpha is
fully visible
this is different because in rgba color
declaration opacity is a small number
between 0
and 1. so why does this array have 40
000 elements
when the area we are scanning is 100
times 100 pixels
and we know hundred times hundred is
only ten thousand
not forty thousand also remember that
this is a special type of array
called clamped array so every element it
contains can only be a number between
zero
and two hundred and fifty-five again
very simple explanation
let's look back at our rgba color
declaration each color
is made out of four properties red green
blue and alpha same with this clamped
array data object
the way it's organized is every four
elements in that array
represent these four color values for
one pixel
so color for pixel one is the first four
numbers in this array
color for pixel 2 is the next four
numbers and so on
that's why we have 40 000 numbers in
this array and we only have 10
000 pixels it's because we need four
numbers to make one color
each number is something between 0 and
255
including the number for alpha opacity
that's why online 70 i check if value is
more than 128 which would be around 50
opacity it's like halfway between 0 and
255
roughly 50 any pixels with more than 50
opacity will be added to our particle
array
each one will create a point in the
final font shape
to extract these values we have our
nested for loops
if particle passed check here inside if
statement
i create a temporary variable i call it
for example position x
and i set it equal to x which is the
variable from line 70 and it represents
number of pixels
in a row that passed our opacity check
i do the same for position y which will
be equal to y from line
69 which represents a row vertical
position
of that pixel we are analyzing right now
so in terms of x and y coordinates it's
a vertical position
of pixel that passed our opacity check
so i cycle through all pixels i check
their opacity value
and if their opacity is more than 50 i
capture
their coordinates in temporary variables
position x and position y
and i call push on particle array which
is my custom array i created to hold
particles for my effect
push method just takes whatever we pass
to it and places it at the end of array
so i pass it new particle which we'll
call particle class constructor
that uses es6 class blueprint we created
earlier
and creates a blank object and assigns
it values and properties
based on the rules we declared in the
blueprint
our particular class constructor expects
two values
to come from the outside for x and y
coordinates so i pass it position x and
position y variables from lines 72 and
remember that this code runs only when
opacity is more than 50
so only these particles from the scanned
area will be added to our array
there is just one more little problem to
sort out as i said clamped array that is
held in text coordinates data object
contains four elements for each pixel we
have ten
thousand pixels but this array has forty
thousand elements
it holds a value for red green blue and
alpha for each pixel
right now i am just checking one pixel
because i passed index
one in that array inside square brackets
here
what i want to do is to cycle through
the entire data array
and take every fourth value because i
know every fourth value stands for
opacity
for each pixel it's always red value
green value
blue value opacity value and so on
so i need to replace one with some code
that will allow us to skip
three elements check the fourth one skip
another three elements
check the next one and so on one way to
do this
is i say in brackets y times four
times data with plus
x times four plus three
remember that we are inside a for loop
so y will be one
then two then three as we cycle through
rows and x will be one
two three as four loop cycles through
pixels in each individual row
this calculation is not very intuitive
just know what i'm doing
is i'm cycling through 40 000 elements
and always skipping three
and checking the fourth one i am not a
math expert so this took me forever to
understand but i think for now it's good
enough for us just to show
just so you know what i'm doing i'm sure
there are simple calculations to lock
every fourth item in an array anyway
i will explore it more when we use this
technique next time
that's it this is how you scan portion
of canvas
filter out pixels with no opacity and
save their coordinates in your own
data array since the font we scanned is
very small
as you can see here we don't want our
particles to cover this small area
we want to spread them out evenly while
keeping the shape of our letter
a so here on line 74 i just multiply
position
x times 10 and
position y times 10.
i made a small mistake on line 71.
earlier i renamed data to text
coordinates but here i still refer to it
as
data let me fix that
and we are drawing particles in the
shape of a letter a
well done this is some advanced coding
i can change spread of the particles and
therefore size of particle text by
adjusting values here on line 74.
since we are taking particles from
certain area and multiplying their
coordinates to spread them around
it's not that easy to move the text left
and right
but i can still do that by adding
adjustment variable here
on line 72 and also on line 73
i call them adjust x and adjust y
and up here on line 6 i declare them and
let's push
x 10 pixels to the right
and why 10 pixels down now you can move
your particle text
shape around anywhere you want by
adjusting these two values
size of the effect can be changed here
on line 76
let me just center it in the middle
and of course you can change the text we
draw here on line 23
some of you might like this effect
already but that's not all i also want
to connect particles that are close
enough with lines
similar to the famous particles.js
constellations effect
but on a text instead on random floating
particles and instead of using a library
we will write our code ourselves
i create a custom function i call
connect its job will be just a cycle
through the array of particles that make
up our letter
and measure distance between each
particle if they are close enough we
will take
coordinates of the first particle and we
draw a line to the coordinates of the
second particle
that's it click the like please if
you're getting value from my tutorials
so i create a for loop that cycles
through the entire particles array
since this for loop will have to run for
every frame of animation
let's optimize it a little bit normally
i would just do nested for loops
and i would compare every particle to
every other particle in the same array
but i don't have to do that the inner
for loop only needs to cycle through the
remaining particles in the array because
all the particles before have already
been compared in previous cycles of the
outer for loop
i'm not sure if i'm explaining it
clearly but let's write some code
and i will try again so in the inner
nested for loop
instead of cyclin through the entire
particle array again
just so i can compare every particle
against every other particle
i will only cycle through particles that
have a higher index
than a because anything with lower index
has already been compared in previous
cycles of the for loop
so here i say let b is equal to a
as long as b is less than particles
array length
b plus plus if you look at line 96 again
when the outer loop runs for the first
time it will cycle through the entire
for loop
in the outer loop and inside the inner
loop as well
but eventually when variable a in the
outer loop reaches number
let's say 50 in the inner loop
we say b is equal to a and we cycle only
through particles from index 50
to the end of the array this will pair
up all individual particles inside
particles array
all i need to do here is calculate their
distance and say if distance is less
than some value
connect them with a line we have already
calculated distance between mouse and
particles
on line 45 so again it's exactly the
same thing
dx variable will hold distance between
two elements we are comparing on the
horizontal x-axis
the ui variable will hold distance
between two points
in this case between particle a and
particle b on vertical y
axis this will give us two sides of
right triangle
and we know that the distance between
these two points is hypotenuse
the longest side of the right triangle
the side that is opposite to the right
angle to calculate it we can use
pythagoras theorem
formula which we learned in school a
long time ago math square root
from dx squared plus d y squared or in
other words
math square root from dx times dx plus
dy times dy so to calculate
dx distance of two particles on the
x-axis
i say particle array a x
minus particle array b x a
and b variables will be changing as we
cycle through both for loops so this
code will compare every particle
against every other particle by the time
the for loop has finished
d y will be particles array a y
minus particles array b y now
we have two sides of imaginary right
triangle
and all we need to do to get distance
between these two particles
is to calculate hypotenuse so math
square root
dx squared plus d y squared
now i can say if distance is less than
100 pixels
i set stroke style to white because we
want white lines
line width will be 2 pixels for example
on canvas
line is the same as arc we used to draw
circle
it is considered to be a path so to
start drawing
i will have to call begin path to draw a
line on canvas
you need to call move2 method to set
starting x and y coordinates
and line 2 method to set target x and y
coordinates
when you do that a line will be drawn
between these two points
each point defined by two coordinates x
and y
so at first i call a ctx move to method
which creates a starting point of a new
path at coordinates we pass
to it we are inside an if statement that
only runs when two particles are close
enough to each other so i just want to
draw a line
from one particle to another the
starting point of the line
will be x and y coordinates of particle
a
that passed our distance check then i
call a line 2
inbuilt canvas method this method simply
said creates a straight line from
coordinates we pass to it
to the last previous point inside the
same path
start and end of path on canvas will be
defined by beginpath and close path
method calls here
so i call line 2 and i pass it x and y
coordinates
of particle b that passed the distance
check
now that you kind of understand how
parts and lines work you might be able
to see that we can keep drawing more and
more paths
like this and create custom complex
shapes but i only want to
draw a single line connecting particle a
and particle b
all you need to do to create the popular
particles.js constellations effect with
vanilla javascript is this code we just
wrote
from line 94 inside our custom connect
function
we have just declared a function we also
need to call it inside our animation
loop to actually run the code
so on line 90 i call connect and here we
go
this is just the basic effect we can
make it a little bit nicer than this
here
on line 105 you can change the distance
limit
the limit will determine maximum
distance between particles
that get connected by white line
i think 50 looks pretty good but for you
it might be slightly different number
depending on your base font and how much
you decided to scale your particle shape
earlier
just try different numbers here and see
what you like one important visual thing
that particles.js library does is that
the lines are not always fully visible
they don't just appear and disappear as
particles move closer
and away from each other lines slowly
fade away and slowly appear again
basically opacity of the lines is
dynamically calculated
based on the distance between particles
it looks much cleaner that way
to do this in our custom code base is
very simple on line 96 i create a new
variable called opacity value
and initially i set it to 1 full
visibility
then here on line 107 i set stroke style
to rgba color declaration
rgb value for white is 255 255 255
and i will concatenate opacity value
variable
as the last fourth attribute for opacity
like this
now we have a variable that can
dynamically change an opacity of lines
will change with it
to make opacity proportionate to the
current distance between particle a and
particle b
i run this strange formula basically
what i want
is if distance is close to zero
particles are very close to each other
so i want opacity to be close to one
as the distance between particles
increases i want to decrease the opacity
value
until particles are far enough and
opacity will be 0.
there are many ways to do this simple
way is to say
1 which is full opacity full visibility
so lines are visible
minus distance divided by 50. notice
that i divided by the same number
don't overthink this let me give you two
examples if distance
is zero particles are close
line is fully visible on the other hand
if distance is 50 1 minus
50 divided by 50 is 1 minus 1 so 0
lines are invisible when the distance
between particle a
and particle b reaches 50 or whatever
you set the limit to
if you want particles to have zero
opacity when they reach maximum distance
keep these two numbers on lines 106 and
107
the same if you change distance to 100
change the formula on line 107 200 as
well
and the effect will work the same lines
will still disappear when they reach
or get very close to maximum distance
here i am struggling a bit because i
didn't notice i forgot one comma
on line 108 inside rgba color
declaration
just bear with me a bit nothing is
changing about the code i'm just trying
to find the problem
now i notice the missing comma and
suddenly everything works
what i will do now i will copy these two
lines and place them outside
the if statement which thinking back was
not necessary because lines are only
drawn
if we enter the if statement on line
107.
now i just restore the formula to
dynamically calculate opacity on line
105
and the base effect is a ton
there are many tweaks that can be done
now to achieve different results
hope you had fun coding with me today if
you did let me know what you've built
html canvas is a powerful tool and it
allows us to do so many things these
days
good luck with your coding studies i
hope to see you again for more creative
coding experiments